it's too easy to go and get rid of a  child it's too easy to go and say well  then i'm gonna get birth control and i'm  gonna sleep with everyone because i'm  gonna i'm not gonna get pregnant it's  not gonna bother me but every the young  people don't realize every time they  sleep with a man you're giving away a  bit of yourself so by the time you've  reached 35 there's hardly anything left  to you because you've given it away to  all these people and they don't realize  that men can sleep with  women i don't mean nothing to them but  women sleep with men and it's emotional  and every time you sleep with a man you  give away a bit of yourself and that's  what the young people don't realize that  they're just giving themselves away bit  by bit by bit